what is up guys number one gaming
YouTube channel bringing you another gay
way hooray smash that subscribe button
right now if you enjoyed this video and
have a good skate already generator
playing a really quirky crazy game so if
you enjoyed it make sure to smash that
subscribe button right now set mash
make sure to smash this oh this game is
so crazy it's called baldies basics
version education the graphics looks
really bad excuse me is it not 2018
what is this mouse sensitivity not to
brag but I'm approached I'll put it on
Lex let's begin this game can't wait
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
smash that like button right now my god
look at the graphics guys - no pulse
before he can use these can you just not
talk to me and look at me or do anything
related to me that would be great thanks
Hey look an open wow this game is easier
than it looks damn it
okay fine twelve ten I hear every door
you open okay
whoa Jesus what the hell is happening
what are you doing in man Clark okay
fine I'll get the notebook my god
nine - okay great
let's see here then break the game what
happened oh okay
what's with the butt smacking no running
in the hall no running in the halls [ __ ]
Jason detention for you when will you
learn Oh will you are what is this game
fine two more seconds why is everyone
making addy sucking face seriously what
what was that
despite her poor Oh
[Laughter]
fantastic okay so what is that what is
this I got a coin okay that's always
good
all right we're just in school this is
like a regular school game
hey we got chocolate now wow what a
great game
what a great game guys well I would have
to review it oh not only rooms in the
halls damn it
detention for you you should know better
I should know better
he's right okay we haven't gotten
spanked yet so I think we'll be all
right
I'm a little spooked out there's
something something not quite right
about this game what the hell was that
all right I guess we just collect more
notebooks all right I'm just gonna do
I'm just gonna do them all correctly
who's angry and why I'm the angry one I
am the one another notebook is there any
point for me to do these oh my god oh
wait
edit that out oh that's right I used to
study math at university everybody okay
we found school cafeteria cool can I use
the item somehow I can't Oh God there is
[ __ ] don't spank me but don't spank me
Oh God Oh God
rondalee no no I run if I walk down damn
it screams leap all right I guess not I
guess we won't go in Oh God that is a
beautiful picture you know I didn't want
to say it but I think we're looking at
some game of the year material here is
there even any point for me to do these
oh wait
I'm a good [ __ ]
we're Jeff Blatnick no no running in the
halls
yeah I don't care damn detention for you
your parents will hear about this one
please don't tell my parents what the
hell is that thing a fidget spinner I
figure spinner
let's not yes of course this game makes
too much sense it hurts okay I play the
cassette oh god he's coming he's coming
he's coming oh oh oh I'm not scared
ain't scared and nobody
hey we got cars everybody yes principals
keys okay that's good
we might need those yes we're doing
great what is this be soda great I'm
glad why did we have that okay all right
our fourth notebook we're doing
absolutely fantastic how am I supposed
to know that I am so okay that phone
can't hurt me
right hello mr. phone oh I have a
quarter
let's not someday
deep inside okay that's great that's
great that's great honey
all right let's check out you how you
how do you do this is a bully okay I'm
not going near the bully that's for sure
that's for you no it's not sweeping time
it has never been sweeping time and
there will never be a sweeping time no
he's coming here by I can hear him oh
there is me sorry I finally it's mine
okay cool
oh this is the where we weren't in the
beginning [ __ ] oh this is real bad this
is real bad guys
what is that Jesus Christ this game is
annoying it's worse than the PewDiePie
video am i right geesh I'm so
ridiculously focused to just beat this
stupid game which I know it's all silly
guys I know it's a little silly of me
raised right there that's fine please
don't sweep
I don't want Jesus Christ well what's
that I know about this one okay so we we
need to go on the right come on two more
[Music]
come on oh god he's so fast now max you
knew him quite well
I know where the last one is why do I'm
not here in here oh god don't think it's
mine oh I'm actually spooked
that's the sweeping room damnit get the
hell out of my way I know where it is I
know where it is I know where it is I
know where it is I know what it is it's
here somewhere it's here somewhere
no no it's right here it's right here
it's right here there come on you three
uh fifteen yeah
patience thank you what does this mean
[Music]
why do I do
I did it guys guys I did it anyway hey
guys we bleeding dead egg boys is
absolutely mental
I didn't even do anything no no no don't
were you back not giving up that easy
boy
Oh God I don't know what exit is I do
not know about that's a class this
ridiculous guys guys ridiculous trying
to I wanna die well that was it for
baldies basic everyone clap it up
everybody if you enjoyed smash that like
button and do remember
[Music]
you wanna hit the flow and I'm never
gonna fly
tell me when it go I'm like whenever I'm
done with this Pastor Mike the Edgar